yo yo
this is john and this is the dr john
dalone show
we talk about your mental health your
relationships
everything going on in the world
everything going on your life
this is the special edition january 1st
new year's day show
and we're going to start things off if
you're watching this on youtube you can
look around we are in
a new studio it is sparkly
and lit up so here's the truth
when we were first talking about
creating the dr john dolone's show
and again it still feels weird to talk
about yourself in
the first person like that we were
talking about starting this podcast
i really pushed for the team here we
wanted to be down in our space where we
figured it out
and we it was dark and it was a little
lit
and it was like felt secretive like we
were in a gang
and then the show took off it's exploded
underneath us
and then it just started looking like we
were doing a show in my mom's basement
and number one she doesn't have a
basement which makes it super weird and
creepy
and number two um she doesn't live in
nashville so that would have been just
weird so
we got promoted we moved up to the big
fancy studio
and now we are here it is lit up
it is beautiful we have the same team
zach and james and kelly we got
everybody here and we have a shelf
some shelves that's cool too we've got
um
same mug everything's the same the same
people except everything's different
so we're starting the new year off we're
going to talk about
goals for a minute and then i'm going to
let you go
but as you're planning for today as
you're
planning for going back to work you may
be back at work you
may be traveling maybe coming home from
traveling whatever it may be
i want us to all remember a couple of
things
oh by the way i'm also celebrating this
new year's show if you're watching this
on youtube by
cutting myself shaving
shaving like lloyd christmas what are
you doing in there i'm shaving
i cut myself shaving the fur look at
that look at that dude
no makeup to cover it up just right
there man
with a mach3 the same mach3 i've been
using since i was about 11. but alas not
the same one but you get what i'm
talking about
the same machine that'd be awesome right
so
as we get ready to enter 2021 i've been
hearing over and over and over and over
for probably the last seven months i
can't wait till this year is over
i can't wait till 2020 is over right
coronavirus schools opening closing job
loss economy travel restrictions
and a partridge in a pear tree right
here's what i can guarantee you
that today january 1 nothing changes
schools are still trying to figure out
what they're doing jobs are still in
jeopardy some states are open some
states are closed hospitals are full
some places hospitals are empty
it's still mowing going on and going on
and going on
right and so if you've put all of your
energy into just
getting through the finish line and
collapsing on the other end now it's
2021 now things are gonna finally be
safe and okay and huh
it's just gonna be a lot like 2020
because the only thing that is going to
change
is what you decide to change in your
heart and your mind and your
actions right we love stability and over
the last 150
years we've had one goal and that is to
create
comfort to create stability to create
certainty right everything about the the
modern and post-modern life is built to
create predictability and comfort
i know this is going to be this way
tomorrow and we
just we we've just become addicted to
comfort we've become addicted to
certainty
and we found out in short order this
last year that neither of those things
are a guarantee in fact the only thing
that's guaranteed is those two things
aren't guaranteed
right so now that we know certainty is
an illusion
i want you to to let you in on a secret
one of the the
the rules of life if you will for me and
that is
most of the things most of the time get
better
and occasionally they get way way worse
rarely but they do and so i like to live
in this optimistic tension
and this with this reality tension
things could be awesome
and we need to always be looking for joy
and beauty and
the the way things could be and oh my
gosh
if we think things are bad it could get
way way way worse right and so as we
head into
2021 today's day one
if you listen to the last podcast right
before new year's we talked about
goal setting this year we're going to
not set up a bunch of goals we're not
going to set up a bunch of resolutions
that
i'm going to lose 30 pounds and i'm
gonna run four marathons and i'm gonna
get a job and make this much money
we're not gonna do that this year we're
gonna go deeper than that we're gonna
talk about who we're gonna be
and so i'm just gonna be open and be
vulnerable here i'm gonna let you know
here's what mine are
and a couple of these i'm gonna explain
them how they work right
so this year surprisingly
not to my third grade english teacher
but to everyone else on earth
uh my employers too we had a
best-selling book right this
the anxiety redefining anxiety hit the
best seller list
it surprised all of us it is sold 10
times plus
more copies than we were expecting right
so my goal for 21 2021 is not to sell a
certain number of books
that's not the goal my goal isn't to um
my goal isn't to make another best
seller list no
my goal of 20 20 21 is to
be somebody who is a writer
what does that mean that means this year
in 2020 i wrote speeches
a tiny little book letters thank you
notes comedy
poetry just a life of a writer
in 2021 i'm going to regulate that which
means i'm going to dedicate
part of my day every day to the craft of
writing
i'm going to live the life of someone
who writes and underneath that is going
to be
all kinds of goals and ideas but the
main arc of that is going to be
i'm going to live the life of a writer
and you know what the next book is going
to take care of itself
the next speech is going to take care of
itself because i'm going to get in the
habit and the practice
of being somebody who writes the next
one is i had a new job
this year it's my first year to work in
radio to work in podcasting and all that
shenanigans i have a new job as a radio
host a podcast host speaker writer
my goal is not to have a bunch of
followers to get a bunch of talks
to get a bunch of new whatevers my goal
is to be
become to continue to become a
world-class communicator
that's different right because i could
have
my goal is to have 30 speeches i could
get 30 speeches and
not be any better at it not listening to
feedback not growing any
just taking a job because it's a job
because it's going to get me my check
off list
no i want to be a world-class
communicator what does that mean
i'm going to work with writers i want to
learn how to do what i do better
i'm going to work with the videographers
we're going to go back and watch
videos you do something awkward give a
speech and then get with a team of
people and break it down
and they ask things like why are you
standing like that why'd you say that
that wasn't even funny
look how your face looks right we're
going to get with
leadership here on the playback right
i'm going to get into the craft of
communicating i'm going to continue to
study stand-up comedians musicians
people who are
professional communicators across
multiple different platforms and then
i'm going to continue to speak and
perform and stretch where i can
but the goal is to become a world-class
communicator not just to get a bunch of
metrics and a bunch of numbers the
metrics in numbers should take care of
themselves
if i become a world-class communicator
if i put in the hard hard work
the humbling humbling vulnerable work
right
my goal is to steward my body so on
january 7th i'm going to start a no
sugar challenge i'm going to invite all
you guys to do that i'll be
talking about this in a later show and
we'll be talking about it on
the social medias but i gotta quit
eating sugar guys
the the i i've come far enough in my
life that i can't deny the research
that sugar contributes to every
single decline in the human body it's
just falling apart
um it's killing us from the inside out
it's killing us from the outside in it's
just bad i gotta stop
and i also have to be graceful with
myself when my daughter has a birthday
party and my son has a birthday party
when i have a birthday party i'm gonna
have a piece of cake because i'm also a
human being too
i'm gonna work out i'm gonna walk i'm
gonna play i'm gonna make movement a
priority
i'm also as a part of being a steward of
my body i'm gonna go to a dentist for
the first time and oh geez
i'm gonna get real blood work done again
and actually sit down with somebody and
go through it
i've been ignoring that for the last few
seasons
i'm gonna really re-double my focus on
sleep and make that a
new numero uno or dose and one or two
priorities in my life sleep first and
everything else will come from that
i'm gonna have a goal of being a steward
of my mind
and so instead of saying i'm gonna read
42 books i'm going to read a book every
week no
i'm going to read and that's going to
include books that's going to include
um good essays it's going to become
include science articles
i'm also going to get into something i
haven't done for a long time and that is
some of the advancements in science tech
i want to get and see some of these
things you can actually watch blood
interactions
you can actually get on the internet and
these extraordinary
doctors and research scientists and
medical researchers
have done some really extraordinary work
with animators you can actually go down
into the human body and see how some of
these things work
it's a biology textbook that has come
alive and those things are fun for me
i also want to learn i got chickens and
sheep and i want to
get get some bees right i want to learn
how to do some things outside that i've
been talking about for years
i've got a massive massive garden me and
my wife and my kids are working on
i want to learn how to do some of the
home repair things that i've had to pay
out over the years i'm gonna actually
learn how to do it
and then i'm gonna pick up the guitar
i've been playing guitar for 30 years or
so i want to pick it back up
and start practicing more regularly but
that all that comes back to want to be
somebody
who is a steward of their mind who
learns new things i want to continue
meeting and learning from mental health
professionals
and i have some transitional theology
questions that i've been rattling around
for the last year or two
that are powerful and really faith
shifting for me in a really
extraordinary way
and so i'm going to spend some time
answering those both experientially both
sitting down with
people who know way more about those
things than i do and through
reading and continuing to delve into
spiritual and faith issues and so
the final one is i'm going to be a
steward of my relationships i'm going to
continue to invest in my wife
continue to invest in my kids continue
to invest in my friendships
i got lonely this year like we all did
but i got lonely this year and i've got
to redouble my efforts on being somebody
who invests in friendships
investing in my local church and that
starts
tomorrow when my wife and i go on our
annual retreat we talk about
what we liked about this year what we
didn't like about this year we go to
some coffee shops around town this year
some of them may be closed we may be out
walking around at different parks or
different hikes or whatever that may
look like but we're going to spend some
time being intentional about being
reflective over last year
what we want this year to look like and
how loosely are we going to hold those
things because who knows what 2021 holds
for us
so make sure you write these things down
the goal here being this as much as it's
been fun to say
god almighty i can't wait till 2020 is
over 2021 may be worse
probably not but maybe and so
given those two realities probably not
but maybe
all you can control is you your thoughts
your actions
your heart your relationships that's it
so write down who you want to be
write down the kind of person you want
to become
who are you gonna be
write them down get somebody in your
life it's going to hold you accountable
and then let's go get it man let's have
an extraordinary year we're going to
have so much fun on this podcast we're
going to get into some hard things some
deep things
we already have calls lined up for the
next few shows it's coming man whether
we want to or not and i'm excited to
have you along this journey with us
as we wrap it up um i had two songs that
are perfect for today
and so i'm just gonna do both of them
i'm gonna start with one of the greatest
songs ever
ever ever written
rem's it's the end of the world as we
know it
and it goes like this michael stipe
sings
it's the end of the world as we know it
and i feel fine
and it just does that for a lot and then
the next song also
is by death cab for cutie
death cab for cutie in a race a neck and
neck race for the
worst band name ever
but this is a great song it's a first
track off their 2003 album
trans atlanticism
trans-atlanticism it's called the new
year
deathcab for cutie the new year
it goes like this so this is the new
year and i don't feel any different
the clanking of crystal explosions off
in the distance
in the distance so this is the new year
and i have no resolutions or
self-assigned
penance for problems with easy solutions
so everybody put your best suit or dress
on let's make believe that we are
wealthy for just this once
lighting firecrackers off on the front
lawn as 30 dialogues bleed into one
i wish the world was flat like the old
days and i could travel just by folding
a map
no more airplanes or speed trains or
freeways there'd be no distance that
could hold us back
not even the social distance there'd be
no distance that could hold us back
so this is the new year so this
is the new year thanks for being with us
look forward to hanging out in 2021
this is the dr john daloni show
you